Oh your mom is lovely yes and I do enjoy
her tweets yes and I found it great that
she was like you know accepted a great
job he can't say no still our fam my
dad's the best singer in the family and
he is a bad singer before we get started
I want to say how much I enjoy Billy on
the street thank you well done you guys
are fantastic together I'm sure you're
hearing that from every single person
walking in the room and stuff you told
me and I think the reason is because you
guys recorded together yeah and so talk
a little bit about what that was like
and because no movies get to do this
they're always separated yeah yeah it
was really a pleasure and then and like
a gift to be able to record together and
a play off each other and you know I
think we both under John's Direction saw
that like as as natural and
conversational as we could make it as
possible and to really as much as
possible seem like we're two very close
friends you were interacting we were
interact all the time and who kind of
step on each other's lines and and
really kind of weave in and out of each
other's dialogue and the it would have
been literally impossible to do if we
weren't physically with each other as we
were doing it so yeah it was I'm glad we
got to do that yeah I agree it made all
the difference in the world and we got
to banter with each other and improvise
with each other in real time and I think
you can feel it in the movie it feels
conversational it feels like it's
happening in the moment and the movie
benefits from it yeah I'm very curious
what you actually because listen a lot
of people I'm sure wanted to do the
movie so what did you pay to be in the
film exactly there's no way I could
afford it to pay more than whatever
James Corden what if they yeah
[Laughter]
exactly outbid Josh gasps next of course
important thing is that you know this is
gonna be a huge thing for Disney did
they give you a free annual passport to
the park yet you know I actually love
Disneyland genuinely but have not been
there since we've been making the movie
I have I brought oh yes I brought my
entire production company to Disneyland
with guides provided to us by Disney oh
my god I have to get out due to my
involvement annoying so I'm obviously
you've both been to the park I love
going to you know do you have a favorite
ride do you what do you enjoy like first
thing you walk in the park what's the
first thing you want to do I love the
old school rides like I love Pirates of
the Caribbean I love it's a small world
and then I also love what's the one in
California Adventure Soren Soren I could
live in Soren yes every movie should be
like Soren Lion King has its soaring
like moments not like Soren is my
favorite thing yeah well I'd pay a lot
to soar for like three hours I wish I
could live in there for like a month
yeah just soar I love the Indiana Jones
ride Splash Mountain I always like oh
you know I've been going to Disneyland
since I was like a very small child and
when I was a kid even though my family
didn't have a lot of money every year my
we would drive from Vancouver to LA and
go to Disneyland like my dad was like
obsessed with it and we get there like
when the park opened and run to the ride
that would then have the three-hour
lineup just to get it out of the way and
it was like a real like weird manic
family tradition we had yeah I already
have to stop and I mean it seriously you
both are so fantastic in this thank you
thank you